la bataille a beau se jouer sur le front
fédéral françois legault c'est que sa
voix compte et celles des québécois
aussi je veux demander aux québécois de
tenir compte des réponses des différents
chefs fédéraux à ces questions très
important sa première demande plus
d'argent pour la santé le gouvernement
du québec souhaite qu'ottawa paie 35 %
et non pas 22 % des dépenses des
provinces et qu'ensuite les transferts
soit augmenté de six pour cent par année
j'insiste sur le sans condition c'est
pas vrai que le gouvernement fédéral
vous venez nous met en tutelle pour
choisir à notre place les priorités du
réseau de la santé avec une demande
claire de cesser les ingérences
l'imposition de conditions toute autre
forme de ce gommage le bloc rappelle
qu'il a fait des transferts la grande
priorité de la campagne les
conservateurs eux répondent en partie
aux exigences de françois legault le
bout 6 % somme est acceptée par le parti
conservateur mais le bout de passer de
22 à 35 %
les paons tendu quant aux libéraux et
aux néo démocrates ils ont droit à une
critique à peine voilée du premier
ministre du québec c'est quand on est un
nationaliste québécois bayadh deux
parties qui sont plus centralisateur le
parti libéral le npd ce candidat libéral
refuse d'y voir un désaveu s'être lâché
aulas privilégié entre le gouvernement
fédéral nos partenaires du vent du
québec a porté fruits pour les québécois
et les québécoises et moi je peux vous
dire que ce cadre-là savoir résister si
les gens nous donnent un prochain mandat
le npd qui a promis une augmentation des
transferts sans conditions ne sont pas
non plus ébranlée on a déjà montré
pendant cette pandémie comment on a aidé
les québécois et québécoises en matière
d'immigration françois legault souhaite
obtenir le contrôle du programme de
regroupement familial
pour l'instant le bloc et les
conservateurs ont exprimé une ouverture
clair cette demande je vais donner plus
de pouvoirs en émigration incluant la
réunification familiale
là où les conservateurs apparaissent
clairement l'opposition avec françois
legault c'est sur toute la question des
garderies le premier ministre du québec
s'attend à ce que l'entente de 6
milliards de dollars conclu avec ottawa
pour financer le réseau des cpe soit
maintenue peu importe le parti au
pouvoir et on nous l'a refusé confirmé
que ce serait le cas s'il était élu
premier ministre ici laurence barthe et
radio canada ottawa